[Music]
as commissioner for health and food
safety
one of my top political priorities is
animal welfare
a file that is as much a priority for
this commission as it is close to my
heart
your voice was heard loud and clear
through the european citizens initiative
and the cage age
you showed us that you want to have your
say and that you want europe to change
course on this issue and i can tell you
that europe will change course on animal
welfare
last june we gave our pledge that we
will by the end of 2023 put forward
legislation to start phasing out the use
of cages for certain farm animals
but we will go further than that
and
as announced in the farm-to-folk
strategy
also in 2023 we will revise all eu rules
on animal welfare our ambition is clear
we want to strengthen and expand the
protections afforded to animals in many
key areas
that includes better living and
transport conditions and enhanced
protection of animals during slaughter
europe needs ambition and conviction to
act on an issue which is so important to
european citizens
to do this
we need your input
and your views
on how to share the proposal
and this is why i turn to you once again
to help us build a better future for
animals in the eu
by letting us know what your concerns
and aspirations are on this important
issue
europe is already a place that respects
nurtures
and upholds the welfare of billions of
animals
whether they roam our countryside graze
our farmlands or form an integral part
of our families as pets
but we need to do more
we want to do more
and we are determined to do more
because animal welfare matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you